This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On July 10th, 2015, a police officer in Prairie View, Texas pulled over a 28-year-old black woman named Sandra Bland. And she was pulled over for turning without signalling, which is a common infraction that police used to stop people in their cars today. This is Sarah Seo, professor at Columbia Law School. And the traffic stopped quickly turned hostile. There was confrontation between the officer about her smoking in her car and the officer got upset. Many of you have probably seen the footage of this arrest. It is very disturbing.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2015年7月10日，在德克萨斯州草原景观市，一名警察拦下了一位名叫桑德拉·布兰德的28岁黑人女性。她被拦下的原因是转弯未打转向灯，这是如今警察在路上拦截车辆时常用的一种违章行为。这是哥伦比亚法学院教授莎拉·塞奥。而这场交通拦检很快变得充满敌意。警察和她就她在车里抽烟一事发生了冲突，警察因此很不高兴。你们许多人可能都看过这次逮捕的录像。画面非常令人不安。
The officer drags bland out of the car and threatens her with a taser. He then arrests her and takes her to jail, where she tragically dies three days later. Blan's death was ruled a suicide, but her treatment at the hands of the police sparked outrage across the country. About a year later, the magazine The Nation published an article trying to analyze everything that went wrong leading up to her arrest. They focused not just on the incident itself, but her entire life's history, her experiences with unemployment, poverty, and mental illness. And when I read the article in The Nation about Sandra Blanc's biography,
警察把布兰德从车里拖出来，并用电击枪威胁她。接着他逮捕了她并将她带进监狱，悲剧的是，三天后她在那里去世了。布兰德的死被裁定为自杀，但她在警方手中的遭遇在全国范围内引发了愤怒。大约一年后，《国家》杂志发表了一篇文章，试图分析导致她被逮捕前发生的一切错误。他们的焦点不仅在于事件本身，还有她的一生经历，她遭遇失业、贫困和精神疾病的经历。而当我读到《国家》杂志上关于桑德拉·布兰德生平的文章时，
one thing that stood out to me was every moment in her life where she experienced a setback happened in the context of her car. Where the police stopped her in her car for a traffic violation, a parking violation that she couldn't afford to pay. And so she sat out in jail or because the police found marijuana in her car that she was using to self-medicate her mental health issues. And so for me, I saw the car as this important character in itself in the systematic ways that black Americans today, black people today in America, are discriminated against, treated unniquely in the justice system.
我注意到的一点是，她生命中经历挫折的每一个时刻，都发生在汽车这个语境中。比如警察因为交通违章在车里拦下她，或是她付不起的停车罚单，导致她只能在监狱里苦熬，或者是因为警察在她用于自我治疗精神健康问题的车里发现了大麻。因此在我看来，汽车本身就成了理解当代黑人美国人、当代美国黑人在司法系统中如何遭受歧视、受到区别对待的系统性问题中的一个重要角色。
Sarah Sayos' new book is called Policing the Open Road, How Cars Transformed American Freedom. And it's basically a historical analysis of how we got into this situation, where police have so much power over people in their cars, where black and round people are stopped and searched disproportionately, and where a minor traffic violation, like failing to use a turn signal, can have deadly consequences.
莎拉·塞奥的新书名为《巡逻开阔道路：汽车如何改变美国自由》。它基本上是一份历史分析，探讨了我们是如何陷入这种局面的：警察对车内人员拥有如此巨大的权力，黑人和棕色人种被不成比例地拦截和搜查，而像未打转向灯这样的小交通违章，也可能带来致命的后果。
Sao brilliantly connects the history of modern policing with the history of the car. It's a riveting read and an important book for this moment, and I wanted to talk with Professor Sao about it. We started 100 years ago at the dawn of the automotive age. All of a sudden, there were hundreds and thousands of mass-produced cars on streets that were not meant for them. These streets were intended for pedestrians, children played in the streets, trawlies,
塞奥巧妙地将现代警务的历史与汽车的历史联系在了一起。这是一本引人入胜的读物，也是当下至关重要的书，我想和塞奥教授聊聊这个话题。我们从100年前的汽车时代曙光开始谈起。突然之间，数百甚至数千辆批量生产的汽车涌上了原本并不属于它们的街道。这些街道原本是为行人准备的，孩子们在街上玩耍，还有电车，
a few horse-drawn carriages that could be afforded by the wealthy, and to have suddenly have dozens and then hundreds and then thousands of cars on these streets created chaos and created traffic. So what did we do to respond to the safety issues that that were the result of thousands of cars being thrown onto city streets that were not designed for cars. So we have to think back to a time before the rules of the road became standardized. There were no moral sense of telling us what are the norms of driving on the road. And so local governments when they addressed the traffic problem had to pass a lot of laws setting forth norms so that everybody drove uniformly because that was the best way
只有富人才负担得起的少数马车，而突然之间街上出现了几十辆、上百辆甚至数千辆汽车，这造成了混乱并引发了交通问题。那么，当成千上万辆汽车涌上并非为汽车设计的城市街道并带来安全问题时，我们是如何应对的呢？我们必须回想一下交通规则尚未标准化之前的时代。那时没有告诉你道路驾驶规范的道德意识。因此，地方政府在解决交通问题时，不得不通过大量法律来确立规范，以便每个人都能统一驾驶，因为这是最好的方式，
to achieve safety on the road. Right, and there were so many of these new laws that ended up being pretty confusing, especially because they varied from state to state and county to county. And so local governments needed to really work to get people to understand these laws and to follow them. Yeah, and they tried a mix of old ways of responding to social problems while searching for new solutions because the car was an innovation that they had not experienced before. And so some of the old ways that they tried to respond was through private voluntary actions. Ministers in churches gave sermons on safety Sunday
来实现道路安全。没错，而且这些新法律多得最终让人感到相当困惑，特别是它们在各州之间、各县之间各不相同。因此，地方政府确实需要努力让人们理解这些法律并遵守它们。是的，他们在寻找新解决方案的同时，尝试将应对社会问题的旧方法结合起来，因为汽车是他们以前从未经历过的创新。因此，他们尝试应对的一些旧方法是通过民间的自愿行动。教堂的牧师在安全星期日发表布道，
exhorting their congregants to obey traffic laws. They also had school boys, preferably boy scouts, direct traffic nearer schools. Washington DC even had women volunteer to manage traffic and report traffic violations. And so some of the old ways of governing relied on private citizens and volunteers to try to maintain order on the streets.
劝诫他们的会众遵守交通法。他们还让男学生，最好是童子军，在学校附近指挥交通。华盛顿特区甚至有女性志愿者来管理交通并举报交通违章。因此，一些旧的治理方式依赖于普通公民和志愿者来试图维持街道秩序。
But these were ineffective, and they were ineffective because average citizens who owned and drove cars refused to obey traffic laws. They kept breaking them. And one of the most common laws that they broke were speeding limits, which was a number one contributing factor tax. And so they realized relying on old ways of governing people,
但这些方法是无效的，之所以无效，是因为拥有并驾驶汽车的普通公民拒绝遵守交通法。他们不断违章。他们违反的最常见的法律之一就是超速限制，这是造成交通问题的第一大因素。因此他们意识到，依赖旧的治理人的方式，
relying on their sense of honor to obey the laws wouldn't work. And so they started shifting towards police law enforcement. And the police at this time, they were not what we think of today. Like police forces were really small. Officers weren't really trained for the job. They were often playing clothes. Maybe they had a little tin star, almost like a night watchman or something. They weren't really in the business of policing the kind of upper middle class, otherwise
依赖他们遵守法律的荣誉感是行不通的。于是他们开始转向警察执法。而当时的警察，跟我们今天的认知完全不同。当时的警力非常小。警员并没有真正接受过该职位的培训。他们通常穿便服。也许他们只有一个小锡星，几乎就像夜间守卫之类的人。他们其实并不负责管束那些中产阶级上层、原本
law abiding people who were all of a sudden driving around in cars and in breaking all these new traffic laws. Exactly, exactly. And so what local governments throughout the country realized was that trying to enforce the law against normally law abiding citizens, the respectable members of society required somebody with more authority. It required somebody with good judgment. It required somebody who knew the laws, right? To stand head to head and toe to toe with the respectable members of society, even the wealthy ones who drove their cars too fast. And what they realized as they needed
遵纪守法却突然开着车到处跑并违反所有这些新交通法律的人。确实，确实如此。因此，全国各地的地方政府意识到，要对通常遵纪守法、社会中受人尊敬的成员强制执行法律，需要更有权威的人。这需要一个有良好判断力的人。这需要一个懂法的人，对吧？能够与社会上受人尊敬的成员、甚至是那些车开得太快的富人正面交锋、针锋相对。而他们意识到自己需要的是，
police officers to be professionals. Right. And so we see because of automobile, a shift to professionalize and modernize police departments who couldn't be bribed, who were smart enough to learn all the laws, who were tall enough, there was actually a height requirement so that they could stand above the cars
让警官成为专业人士。没错。因此我们看到，由于汽车的出现，警察部门转向了专业化和现代化，他们不能被收贿，他们聪明到足以学习所有的法律，他们身高足够高——实际上当时有身高要求，这样他们才能站在汽车上方，
and people could see their directions managing traffic. And so we see how the police profession itself become more specialized and exclusive out of necessity because of the need to discipline drivers. So was the decision to involve the police and all this like controversial? I mean, I mean, today we take it for granted that police enforced traffic laws, but was there any debate about that at the time? There was debate. There was a group of reforming police chiefs who wanted to modernize and professionalize the police. And the person at the forefront of that movement was a police chief named August Wilmer.
人们才能看到他们指挥交通的手势。因此我们看到，出于管理司机的需求，警察这一职业本身由于必要性变得更加专业化和排他性。那么，让警察介入这一切的决定在当时是不是很有争议？我的意思是，今天我们认为警察执法交通是理所当然的，但在当时对此有什么辩论吗？确实有辩论。有一群希望使警察现代化和专业化的改良派警察局长。这场运动的领头人是一位名叫奥古斯特·沃尔默的警察局长。
He was a police chief of Berkeley, California, from 1905 to 1932. And a lot of police scholars today call him the father of modern policing in America. And he firmly believed that the police should not enforce traffic. He also believed that the police should not enforce vice laws because the police as professionals were crime fighters and they should devote their time to fighting and investigating crime, not enforcing traffic laws or vice laws like prostitution or anti-licor laws. Right. He didn't see those as serious crimes worthy of the police's attention. It
他是1905年至1932年加利福尼亚州伯克利的警察局长。今天许多警察学者称他为美国现代警务之父。他坚信警察不应该执法交通。他还认为警察不应该执行风化法，因为作为专业人士的警察是打击犯罪的人，他们应该把时间花在打击和调查犯罪上，而不是执行交通法或诸如卖淫或禁酒令之类的风化法。没错。他并不认为这些是值得警察关注的严重犯罪。这
was more of an administrative task than professional police work. Yeah, and I think the other thing is that traffic quickly came to consume much of the police's time. It became a large part of their duties. And for the police to enforce the letter of the law against these ordinarily law-abiding citizens proved to be a huge headache because nobody liked being enforced. Nobody liked to be ticketed.
与其说是专业警察工作，不如说是一项行政任务。是的，而且我认为另一件事是，交通很快就耗去了警察的大部分时间。它成了他们职责的很大一部分。而且警察对这些平时遵纪守法的公民执行法律字面规定，结果证明是一件非常令人头疼的事，因为没有人喜欢被执法。没有人喜欢吃罚单。
Nobody liked to be arrested for a traffic violation. And so what Womor saw was that what he called the respectable citizenry started turning against the police. And he hated that because police as professionals were owed respect, not to stain. And so what he realized to manage this kind of public relations rule of law problem was to advise his officers, actually exercise your judgment and discretion. And let's not enforce the law to the letter. Let's mitigate the harshness of the law, even if the law says to arrest somebody for
没有人喜欢因交通违章而被捕。因此，沃尔默看到的是，他所谓的受人尊敬的市民开始反对警察。他讨厌这一点，因为作为专业人士的警察应该赢得尊重，而不是鄙视。因此，为了处理这种公关和法治问题，他意识到的解决办法是建议他的手下：实际上，要行使你们的判断力和自由裁量权。我们不要照本宣科地执法。我们要减轻法律的严苛性，即使法律规定因交通违章而逮捕某人，
a traffic violation. Let's just let them go with the warning. It's better to manage our relations with the citizen rather than to antagonize and alienate them. So he definitely saw the challenges of traffic law enforcement that he did not like at all. Right, even though his opposition didn't end up mattering that much, it was like this is an interesting irony that you present in the book is that cars ended up helping Boomer achieve his goals in having a more modern professional police force. Because so many people were breaking traffic laws that meant they had to have more police, more police officers on the road, and they needed their own patrol cars, and all the traffic tickets helped pay for all of it.
我们也放他们一马，给个警告就行了。与其激怒和疏远公民，不如处理好我们与公民的关系。因此，他确实看到了交通执法带来的挑战，而他非常不喜欢这一点。没错，尽管他的反对最终并没有那么重要，但你在书中提出了一个有趣的讽刺，那就是汽车最终帮助沃尔默实现了他建立一个更现代、更专业的警察队伍的目标。因为有那么多人在违反交通法，这意味着他们必须拥有更多的警察，路上需要更多的警员，他们需要自己的巡逻车，而且所有的交通罚单都有助于支付这一切的费用。
Exactly. And what he didn't entirely anticipate, but what happened pretty quickly was that American society became a car society. And so a lot of crime was taking place in cars on the road anyway. And so very early on, local and state government officials were realizing that crime fighting and
没错。而他没有完全预料到、但很快就发生的事情是，美国社会变成了一个汽车社会。因此，大量的犯罪无论如何都在路上的汽车中发生。因此，很早的时候，地方和州政府官员就意识到，打击犯罪和刑事调查中很大一部分都发生在路上，交通警察在寻找安全违章行为的同时，也可以顺便寻找其他犯罪的证据。因此，我们看到了交通执法与刑法执法以及风化法执法职责的融合。当然，这是一个全国禁酒令生效的时期，而汽车是运输酒类的最佳方式之一。
criminal investigation, a lot of it was happening on the road, and that traffic cops while they were looking for safety violations could also look to see if there were evidence of other crimes. And so we see this merging of the duties between traffic enforcement and criminal law enforcement and vice enforcement. This is a period of course where national prohibition is an effect and cars were one of the best ways to transport liquor. Right and so this becomes a major fourth amendment question and that's the amendment that protects against undue searches and seizures. And you know, like we all know, you know, probably from watching TV, that the
没错，这就成了一个重大的第四修正案问题，也就是那个保护公民免受不当搜查和扣押的修正案。你知道的，正如我们大家可能从看电视中所知道的那样，警察需要搜查令才能搜查你的房子，但他们实际上不需要搜查令就能搜查你的汽车。你知道这究竟是什么时候决定的吗？这是一个在20世纪20年代首次出现的问题，当时禁酒令正在生效，汽车的大规模生产已经在美国文化中扎根。之所以警察是否需要搜查令才能拦截并搜查汽车这个问题在20世纪20年代变成如此大的一个议题，是因为私酒贩子意识到运输非法私酒的最佳方式之一就是用他们的汽车。
police need to get a warrant to search your house, but they actually don't need a warrant to search your car. You know, when did that get decided? It's a question that first comes up in the 1920s at a time when prohibition is an effect, and the mass production of cars has really settled in the American culture. And the reason why this question of whether the police need a warrant to stop in such a car becomes such a big issue in the 1920s is because bootleggers realized that one of the best ways to transport their illicit liquor is in their cars.
而警察和禁酒探员想要拦截汽车并进行搜查，但他们没有、也没有时间去获取搜查令。他们希望能够不需要搜查令就做到这一点。这是一个非常棘手的问题，因为第四修正案禁止对人身、住宅、文件和财物进行不合理的搜查和扣押。写宪法时显然还没有汽车，但它们在这个场景中可以被视为财物。因此，这种紧张关系在禁酒令时期浮现出来，即如果警察怀疑车内人员在走私酒精，在没有搜查令的情况下搜查汽车是否妥当。而这种
And police officers and prohibition agents want to stop cars and search them and they don't, they didn't have time to get a warrant. And they want, so they wanted to be able to do that without a warrant. And this is a really hard issue because the fourth amendment prohibits unreasonable search and seizures of persons houses papers on effects. Cars obviously weren't around when the Constitution was written, but they could be thought of as a fact in this scenario. And so this tension emerged during the prohibition era, but whether it's okay for the police to search a car without a warrant if they suspect that people inside are smuggling alcohol. And this
紧张关系在1925年的卡罗尔案中在法庭上达到了白热化。卡罗尔案是美国最高法院审理的第一起汽车搜查案件。该案于1925年裁决，但实际上在1923年就已经提交到了法院。由于案件涉及的问题极其棘手，他们不得不进行第二次辩论。案件的起因是三名禁酒探员
tension comes to a head in the courts in 1925 with the Carol case. The Carol case was the US Supreme Court's first car search case. It was decided in 1925, but it actually came before the court in 1923. And they had to argue it again a second time because the issues were so difficult. The way that the case started was with three prohibition agents
和一名来自密歇根州的公共安全官员。他们看到一辆招摇的奥兹莫比尔敞篷车从他们身边开过。警官们认出了这辆车。它属于一个被称为卡罗尔兄弟的知名私酒贩帮派。于是警察决定追上去。当他们看到这辆车时，并没有任何证据表明
and a public safety officer from the state of Michigan. They saw a flashy, oldsmobile, convertible, drive past them. And the officers recognized the car. It belonged to a gang of known bootleggers called the Carol Brothers. And so the police decided to go after it. They didn't have any evidence at that time that they saw the car.
车里当时有酒。他们只知道卡罗尔兄弟涉嫌走私私酒。于是他们拦下了汽车并进行了搜查。他们什么也没找到。他们正要放走卡罗尔兄弟时，其中一人敲击了后座内衬里面的某个硬物。于是他们撕开内衬，发现在后座里缝了大约80多瓶酒。卡罗尔兄弟试图贿赂他们，但他们拒绝了贿赂并对此案提起了诉讼。
There was liquor in the car at the time. They just knew that the Carol Brothers were involved in bootlegging. So they stopped the car and they searched it. And they couldn't find anything. They were about to let the carol brothers go until one of them hit something hard inside the upholstery of the backseat. And so they tore open the upholstery and they found 80-some bottles of liquor sewn into the backseat. The carol brothers tried to bribe them off but they refused the bribe and they prosecuted the case.
卡罗尔兄弟的辩护律师辩称，警察根本没有办法事先知道车里有酒。因此，根据第四修正案，这次搜查是非法的。法院的法官实际上认为这很有道理，但他们还是在一个至今仍深远影响我们生活的判决中做出了对卡罗尔兄弟不利的裁决。他们写道，汽车彻底改变了美国社会，因此需要与其他形式的财产区别对待。法院为第四修正案创设了一个汽车例外原则。因此，美国最高法院在1925年卡罗尔案中确立的新宪法规则基本上仍然是今天的法律，即如果警察有相当理由相信车内有犯罪证据，
The defense attorneys for the Carol Brothers argued that there was no way for the police to have actually known in advance that there was liquor in the car. And so the search was illegal under the Fourth Amendment. And the justice in the court actually thought that this made sense, but they ruled against the Carol Brothers anyway in a decision that we are still living with today. They wrote that cars had so thoroughly changed American society that they needed to be treated differently from other forms of property. The court created an automobile exception to the Fourth Amendment. And so the new constitutional rule that the US Supreme Court set forth in the 1925 Carol case is basically still the law today, which is if a police officer has probable cause to believe that there's
他们就可以在没有搜查令的情况下拦截汽车。这是一个巨大的改变。警官不再需要去法官面前确定是否有理由进行搜查，而是现在由警官自己做出这种判断。如果他们后来被起诉，警察只需要对法官说：“你知道的，根据我在路上看到的一系列事实，我有相当理由。”
evidence of a crime inside the car, they can stop the car without a warrant. This was a huge change. Instead of needing to go before a judge to determine whether there are grounds to make a search, the officer now had to make that determination for themselves. And if they got sued later on, the police just needed to tell the judge, you know, I had probable cause because of these set of facts that I saw on the road.
而法官和法院在整个20世纪所做的事情，被批评者称为司法宽容。换一种说法，法院经常相信警察关于相当理由的陈述。因此，随着时间的推移，在整个20世纪，相当理由已经演变成了一个非常宽松的标准。卡罗尔案的影响超越了汽车本身。40年后的特里诉俄亥俄州案中，
And what judges and courts have done throughout the 20th century is exercise what critics have called judicial charity. Another way to put it is courts have often believed the police's account of probable cause. And so over time, over the 20th century, probable cause has become this very loose standard. The impact of the Carol case went beyond cars. 40 years later in Terry versus Ohio,
最高法院将拦截和搜身合法化，他们为这一决定辩护的依据就是卡罗尔案。法院接受了卡罗尔案的逻辑，即第四修正案必须发展以保持合理性，从而适应现代世界的环境，因此法院采纳并引用了卡罗尔案的判决来支持这一观点。第四修正案保护公民免受不当搜查和扣押，但在整个20世纪，什么构成合理的搜查一直很难明确界定。
the Supreme Court legalized stop and frisk, and they justified that decision by pointing to Carol. The Court accepted the logic of Carol that the Fourth Amendment had to evolve to be reasonable to meet the circumstances of a modern world, and so it adopted and cited the Carol decision for that proposition. The Fourth Amendment protects against unreasonable searches and seizures, but over the course of the 20th century, what constitutes a reasonable search has been pretty hard to pen down.
第四修正案的合理性分析中，有一个短语在案件中经常出现。什么是合理取决于全部情况。每个案件都必须根据其自身情况逐案裁决。因此，当每个案件都依据其自身情况进行裁决，且警察出庭作证解释他或她为何采取这种或那种行为时，法官很可能会说：“你是对的。我无法事后诸葛亮地去评判你的做法。
Fourth Amendment, Reasonableness Analysis, has this phrase that comes up a lot in the cases. What is reasonable depends on the totality of the circumstances. Each case has to be decided on its own, case by case. And so when you have each case decided on its own and the police comes before the court testifying us to why he or she acted in this way or that way, a judge is likely to say, you're right. I can't judge what you did in hindsight.
你的工作很不容易，而且常常很危险。我选择给你一些信任。”因此，第四修正案关于合理性的判定在绝大多数情况下都站在了警察一边。随着时间的推移，这赋予了警察极大的自由裁量权。不断增大的自由裁量权对警务工作的种族动态产生了怎样的影响？关于自由裁量权的历史，有趣的一点是，在20世纪初，自由裁量权被视为对公民有利的事情。因为行使自由裁量权的警官可以说：“你超速了。但我将行使我的自由裁量权，
What you do is a difficult job, often dangerous. I'm going to give you the benefit of the doubt. So, fourth amendment, reasonableness determinations have for the most part cited with the police. And over time, that has just given police a lot of discretionary authority. And how has the increased discretionary power impacted the racial dynamic of policing? So the interesting thing about the history of discretionary power is that in the early 20th century, discretionary power was seen as a good thing for citizens. Because an officer who exercises discretion could say, you violated the speed limit. But I'm gonna exercise my discretion
放你一马，给你个警告。下次别再犯了，对吧？”但警察在对待穷人和有色人种时行使自由裁量权的方式，是拦截黑人和棕色人种司机的频率高于白人司机。他们行使自由裁量权搜查黑人和棕色人种司机汽车的频率也高于白人司机。而且通常情况下——这是根据斯坦福开放警务项目进行的一项研究所得出的结论——
and just let you go off with the warning. Don't do it again, right? But the police exercise their discretion with respect to the poor and people of color, to pull over black and brown drivers more often than white drivers. They exercise their discretion to search the cars of black and brown drivers more often than white drivers. And oftentimes, and this is based off of a study conducted by the Stanford
当涉及到有色人种司机时，他们常常在几无怀疑甚至毫无怀疑的情况下就去搜查汽车。因此，今天的自由裁量权允许警察以歧视性的方式行使他们的权力。没错。我的意思是，如果我们回到桑德拉·布兰德的案子上，你知道的，我想我们不能百分之百确定这就是种族 profiling（种族定性），但是你……她未打转向灯，而警察选择将这个小违章作为借口，走得更远。我想其中令人不安的是，并不能真正清楚地看出警察在技术上做了什么违法的事。
Open Placing Project, oftentimes they search cars with little suspicion or no suspicion at all when it comes to drivers of color. And so discretion today allows the police to exercise their authority in discriminatory ways. Right. And I mean, if we go back to the Sandra Blancase, you know, I guess we can't say for sure it was racial profiling, but you, but she failed to use a turn signal and the officer chose to use that minor infraction as an excuse to go much further. And I guess what's disturbing about it is that it's not really clear that the officer did anything technically illegal. Yeah, the New York Times asked three or four legal scholars to look at the video of the
是的，《纽约时报》邀请了三四位法律学者观看这段执法的视频，并回答这样一个问题：拦下桑德拉·布兰德的警察所做的事情是否师出有名？他们都认为警察做得过头了，但他们无法绝对肯定地这么说，因为宪法法律几乎允许了他采取的所有行动。警察可以因小交通违章而进行逮捕。这是合理的警务工作。因此，“合理性”的定义已经变得非常广泛和包容。
encounter and answer the question was the officer who pulled over Sandra Blonde justified in doing what he did. And they all believe that the officer went too far, but they couldn't say that definitively because constitutional law allowed almost all of the actions that he took. The officer can make an arrest for a minor traffic violation. That's reasonable policing. And so the definition of reasonableness has become very broad and capacious.
是的。我的意思是，我觉得这一切同时发生令人惊奇的地方在于，你拥有了这种新技术——汽车，它被创造出来。它接管了美国社会。它是一个第四修正案保护力度减弱的地方，也是一个你可能会受到任性管治的地方，因为你随时可能触犯一连串的规则，从而随时可能被拦截。
Yeah. I mean, that's the thing that I find sort of amazing about all this stuff happening at once, is you have this technology, this thing, the car, is created. It takes over American society. And it is a place of diminished fourth amendment protections and a place where you can be policed, you know, kind of capriciously because of the litany of rules that you could possibly be breaking at any one moment in which you could be stopped.
因此，它创造了一个完美的真空，而警察的自由裁量权正好填补了这一真空。是的，而且我认为，我认为一个重要的一点是思考交通法的背景。几乎每个人在某个时刻都会违反某种交通法，超速是很常见的一种。因此，警察可以挑选因交通违章而拦下谁。而在那次交通拦检期间，他们可以寻找构成搜查汽车的相当理由的事实。
And so it creates this perfect void where the discretion of the officer just fills that void. Yeah, and I think, I think an important point is to think about the context of traffic laws. Almost everybody violates some traffic law at some point, speeding as a common one. So the police officer can choose who to pull over for traffic violation. And during that traffic stop, they can look for facts amounting to probable cause to search a car.
因此，你拥有了与卡罗尔规则相融合的交通执法，如果警察想要开始调查，这就赋予了他们极大的自由裁量权。再加上20世纪针对汽车确立的所有其他学说。法律的另一个领域是同意学说，即
And so you have traffic law enforcement merging with the carol rule, which gives police officers a lot of discretionary power if they want to start investigating. And add to that, all these other doctrines that have been established over the 20th century with respect to cars. Another area of law is a consent doctrine, which
如果警察获得了你搜查汽车的同意，那么第四修正案就不适用。因此，一个常见的场景是，交警或巡警因交通违章拦下某人。寻找可能构成相当理由的事实，但同时也问：“我能搜查你的车吗？”一旦他们得到了这个同意，他们就不再需要相当理由了。许多搜查都是通过获得同意来完成的。
is if an officer gets your consent to search your car, then the Fourth Amendment doesn't apply. And so a common scenario is a traffic or a patrol or an officer stops someone for traffic violation. Looks for a fact that might amount to probable cause, but also asks, can I search your car? And once they have that, they don't be probable cause anymore. And a lot of searches are done through consent.
根据警察的性格，他们可以人为制造出相当理由，因为如果警察反应激烈而人们进行反击、或者有任何反抗反应、或者坚持认为自己在人身或这个空间上拥有某种权利——这正是桑德拉·布兰德案中发生的情况。我的意思是，没有任何理由说明她抽根烟就一定会惹恼警察并导致事态升级。正因为如此，事态升级到了她被捕并最终死亡的地步。
And depending on the disposition of the officer, they can create probable cause because if they react violently and people push back or react at all or stand up for themselves or assert that they have some kind of right in their person or in this space, this is what happened with the Central Plank case. I mean, there's no reason why he necessarily had to be offended by her having a cigarette that escalated that incident. Because of that, it escalated to the point that she was arrested and she died.
所以再次说明，它只是造成了这样一团乱麻：由于技术和法律的交汇以及我们执法的方式，一个人拥有了过多的权力。我要补充的是，早在1925年卡罗尔案判决出炉时，批评者就已经预测到了这一点。对吧？曾有一位批评者说，合理或相当理由是一个允许警察在某些情况下出错的标准。现在，如果你有了这种标准，警察就可以稍微捏造一下事实，甚至伪造相当理由。因此，这些批评者已经在预料
And so again, it just creates this mess of things where one person has too much power because of this confluence of technology and law and how we police it. And I would add that critics had predicted this as soon as the 1925 Carol decision came out. Right? There was one critic that said, reasonable or probable cause is a standard that allows the police to be wrong in some circumstances. Now if you have that kind of standard, a police officer can fudge the truth a little bit, maybe even falsify probable cause. So these critics are already anticipating
无搜查令汽车搜查的相当或合理理由标准可能会带来的滥用。我们在今天看到了这一点，去年纽约州的一位法官曾抱怨大麻气味成为警察陈述相当理由时的一种老套路，因为大麻气味是支持相当理由的一个事实。但在法庭审判中，你如何在事后反驳车里根本没有大麻气味？
the abuse that could happen with the probable or reasonable cause standard for warrantless car searches. We see that today, there was a New York state judge last year who complained about the odor of marijuana as this kind of cliche in police accounts of probable cause because the odor of marijuana is a fact that supports probable cause. But how do you disprove that there was odor of marijuana in the car later in a court of law?
这真的归结为法官是否相信警察曾闻到车里有大麻气味。除了质疑警察的信誉之外，当事人无法做任何其他事情来反驳这一事实，因此大麻气味已经变成了这种真正常见的事情，警察会把它加入到对全部情况的陈述中，以此来支持相当理由。是的。
It really comes down to whether the judge believes the police officer that he or she smelled marijuana in the car There's nothing else that a person can do to disprove that fact other than to challenge the credibility of the officer and so this odor of marijuana has become challenge the credibility of the officer. And so this order of marijuana has become this really a common thing that officers will add to their account in the totality of the circumstances to support probable cause. Yeah.
我的意思是，令人惊奇的一件事情是，我是一个40多岁的白人男性。我请得起好律师。如果一个警察把车停在我车后面，而我只是在做我自认为很正常、遵守规则的事情时，我还是会感到害怕。你知道的，就像我觉得自己做了错事，或者觉得我有做错事的潜在可能。我甚至无法想象对于一个处境与我不同的人、对于一个面临更高风险的黑人男性来说，那会是什么感觉。
I mean, one of the things that's pretty amazing is that I'm a white man in his 40s. I can afford to hire a good lawyer. And if a police officer pulls behind me in my car, while I'm just what I think of is behaving normally and at hearing to the rules, I get scared. You know, like I think I've done something wrong or I think there's the potential that I will do something wrong. And I can't even imagine what that is like for someone not in my situation, for a black man with a risk of so much higher.
为什么我们要接受这一点？为什么我们要接受这种动态，即单个警察对车内的人拥有如此巨大的权力？我想我们接受了这一点，我认为法官们之所以接受它，是因为汽车带来的危险。汽车真的很危险。道路安全是一个大问题。我害怕酒驾司机。
Why have we accepted this? Like, why have we accepted this dynamic where an individual police officer has so much power over a person in their car? I think we accept it, and I think the reason my judges have accepted it is because of the dangers of cars. Cars are really dangerous. Road safety is a big issue. I am scared of drunk drivers.
它们是路上的一个巨大问题，对吧？我希望在路上得到保护。我希望得到国家的保护。这是政府的一个合法职能。只是因为我们将这一任务委派给了同时也处理刑事执法的警察，这导致了我们今天看到的许多问题。因此，我认为对于你提出的“为什么我们没有质疑警察对交通法的执法”这一问题，部分答案可以追溯到交通安全是一个大事。但我们可以质疑
There are a huge problem on the road, right? I want to be protected on the road. I want to be protected by the state. That is a legitimate function of the government. It's just that because we've delegated that task to the police that also handles criminal enforcement. That's caused so much of the problems we see today. And so I think part of the answer to your question of why haven't we questioned the police enforcement of traffic laws, as I think goes back to traffic safety is a huge deal. But we can question whether
警察是否是处理这件事的合适机构？休息之后，我们将来看看一个正在这样做、在这次之后将交通执法与其警察部门分离的城市。所以，我住的小镇，加利福尼亚州伯克利，我住在伯克利，总部位于美丽美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，但我住在伯克利。这里也是现代警务之父、警察局长奥古斯特·沃尔默的故居。实际上，他住在我家转角附近。但正如莎拉·塞奥在她的书中谈到的那样，沃尔默并不赞成警察应该负责执行交通法的观点。
the police are the right institution to handle that or not? Coming up after the break, we're going to take a look at a city that is doing just that, separating traffic enforcement from its police department after this. So the town I live in, Berkeley, California, I live in Berkeley, the headquarters is in beautiful downtown Oakland, California, but I live in Berkeley. It was also the home of the police chief August Volommer, the so-called father of modern policing. Actually, he lived like around the corner from my house. But as Sarah Sayow talks about in her book, Vommer was not a fan of the idea that police should be in charge of enforcing traffic laws.
他并不认为开车滑过停止标志是什么值得警察关注的犯罪。因此，一百年后，伯克利市做出了一个奥古斯特·沃尔默可能会赞同的决定。是的，所以在2020年7月，伯克利市议会通过了一项关于警务的重大综合动议。其中的一项战略与交通有关。那是制作人埃文·菲茨杰拉德。你好，埃文。
He did not consider rolling through a stop sign to be a crime worthy of the police's attention. So a hundred years later, the city of Berkeley has made a decision that August Vommer might have approved of. Yeah, so in July of 2020, Berkeley City Council passed this big omnibus motion related to policing. And one of the strategies in there had to do with traffic. That's producer Evan Fitzgerald. Hello, Emmett.
嗨。那么请解释一下那里到底发生了什么。因此，市议会基本上正在开始将交通执法权从其警察部门手中剥离出来的进程。他们投票决定创建一个新机构——交通运输部（简称伯克利交通局，或称Burk dot）。除了负责交通工程和更多结构性事务之外，该机构还将负责管理道路规则。这还处于非常早期的阶段，但这就是他们的意图。这就是他们着手要做的事情。而我发现非常有趣的一件事是，这个提案的整个构想实际上部分受到了莎拉·塞奥的书的启发。我们受到了莎拉·塞奥的书的影响，因为我认为它带来的是这样一种理念：事情并不非得是这样的。
Hey. So explain what actually happened there. So the council is basically beginning the process of taking traffic enforcement out of the hands of its police department. They voted to create a new body, the department of transportation or or Burke dot as they're calling it. Which in addition to doing all the things like traffic engineering and more structural stuff would also administer the rules of the road. And this is very much in the early stages, but that's the intention. That's what they're setting out to do. And one thing that I found so interesting was that the whole idea for this proposal was actually inspired in part by Sarah Sayos' book. We're influenced by Sarah Sayos' book because I think what it brought forward is this idea that it doesn't have to be this way.
这是巴纳利·古什。她是伯克利的一位交通倡导者。她是名为“步行骑行伯克利”的社区组织的协调委员会成员，也是伯克利交通委员会的主席，该委员会是一个就交通问题向伯克利市议会提供咨询的机构。古什说，“步行骑行伯克利”的一位同事实际上在另一个播客《伟大的汽车战争播客》（去听听看）上听到了莎拉·塞奥的演讲。这让他们对所有这些历史产生了兴趣，特别是对奥古斯特·沃尔默产生了兴趣。你知道的，沃尔默被视为现代警务之父，
This is Barnale Gouche. She's a transportation advocate here in Berkeley. She's on the coordinating committee of a community organization called Walk Bike Berkeley and is the chair of the Berkeley Transportation Commission, which is a body that advises Berkeley City Council on transportation issues. Ghost says that one of her colleagues at Walkbike Berkeley actually heard Sarah Sayos speak on another podcast, the Great War on Cars podcast, check it out. And that got them interested in all this history, and particularly in August Volmer. You know, Volmer, who is the, who's seen often as the father of modern policing, um,
他身上有各种各样的问题，但即使是他，甚至这位现代警务之父，也不认为交通执法应该成为警察部门的一部分。这也是我们从莎拉·塞奥的书中学到的东西。是的，我的意思是，我完全被那一节吸引了，觉得它简直非同寻常。是的，这促使古什、“步行骑行伯克利”以及其他社区团体的人们思考：事情非得是这样的吗？我想很长一段时间以来，我们所有人都认为，
all kinds of issues with him, but even he, even the father of modern policing, didn't think that traffic enforcement should be part of the police department. And that's something we also learned from, from Sarah Soes book. Yeah, I mean, I was totally riveted by that section and thought it was just kind of remarkable. Yeah, and that just got gauche and the folks that walk by Berkeley and other community groups thinking, like, does it have to be this way? I think for a long time, we all took it
警察来执行交通执法是理所当然的。但你实际去思考一下，我们越是把这个想法分享给人们，就越能变得非常清楚：你并不需要手持武器的警察去给一个可能在红绿灯变换前几分钟走下马路牙子的人开罚单。而且你知道的，古什长期以来一直致力于交通问题，关注安全问题以及我们如何重新设计城市以使其更安全、减少对汽车的依赖。她说执法工作
for granted that of course police is going to do traffic enforcement. But you actually think about it, the more we share this idea with people, it becomes quite clear that you don't need armed police to ticket somebody who might have stepped off the curb a few minutes before the light change. And you know, Gosh has been working on transit issues for a long time on, you know, questions
一直以来都是让社区中每个人都支持这一理念的主要障碍。我们确实对危险的汽车有很多愤怒。当人们把车停在自行车道上时，我们会感到沮丧。执法被视为创造安全街道的一种工具。但作为交通倡导者，我们真的很厌倦将交通安全作为拦下人们的一种方式。我们社区里的人，尤其是黑人社区成员，一直在告诉我们：我们不希望社区里有更多的警察，
of safety and how we can redesign our cities to make them safer and rely less on cars. And she says that enforcement, you know, has always been a major obstacle to getting everyone in the community on cars. And she says that enforcement has always been a major obstacle to getting everyone in the community on board. We do have a lot of anger against cars which are dangerous. We are upset when people park in the bike lane. And enforcement is seen as a tool to create safe streets. But we as transportation advocates are really tired of using transportation safety as a way to stop people. The folks in our community, especially black community members, we're telling us we do not want more police in our neighborhoods
以此来换取你的安全。所以我们已经在开始思考从包容性视角来看安全是什么样的了。不仅是不被汽车撞到，而且在街头行走时也不受警察的骚扰。好的，所以伯克利创建了这个新的交通运输部，从理论上讲它将监督交通执法。但具体是怎样的呢？比如谁会是那个拦下别人并开出超速罚单的人？是的，所以我问了巴纳利·古什这个问题。
so you can have safety. So we were already beginning to think about what safety looks like from an inclusive perspective. So not just not getting hit by a car, but also not being harassed by a police when you're out walking in the streets. Okay, so Berkeley has created this new Department of Transportation that theoretically will oversee traffic enforcement. But what is that like specifically? Like who will be the person who like stops someone to give them a speeding ticket? Yeah, so I asked Bernali Gosha about this.
同样，这还处于非常非常早期的阶段。因此并没有具体的答案。但她给了我一个建筑检查员的比喻。如果一个建筑检查员进来检查你的房子是否符合规范，他们进你家时是不会带着枪的，
And again, it's like the very, very early stages of this. And so there is no concrete answer to that. But she gave me the analogy of a building inspector. So if a building inspector is coming in to check if you are up to code, they're not carrying a gun to enter your house. You know, expecting that they might find drugs. So why is it okay then to use a violation of traffic safety
指望他们可能会发现毒品。那么，为什么把违反交通安全当作借口，去升级到超越这本身的事情就是可以接受的呢？这是一个很好的隐喻。所以，类似于建筑检查员，但负责交通，就是这样。是的，我想差不多就是这样，一个精通交通和运输问题的无武装人员。而且至关重要的是——这是谈话中一个有趣的部分——至关重要的是，古什指出，这个人也可以成为工程设计和改善我们街道工作的一部分。
to escalate to something more than that? That's a good metaphor. So something like the building inspector, but for traffic is the thing. Yeah, I think something kind of like that, an unarmed person who is an expert in traffic and transportation issues. And crucially, and this was an interesting part of the conversation. Crucially, ghost is a person that could also be a part of the effort to engineer and make our streets better.
因此，那个人可以在应对特定事件的同时，还能从城市设计的角度帮助提供关于哪里出错了的数据。他们将能够向交通运输部汇报，指出究竟是哪些基础设施问题可能导致了人们犯错：是他们看不到停止标志吗？是被树枝挡住了吗？对吧？因此我们希望这个人可以是一个主要优先事项是交通安全、而不是寻找犯罪的人。古什在我们的对话中非常强调这一点：交通执法应该始终与更好的设计和工程相结合。因此，每当发生违章时，你都要问：这些
So that person could use, you know, in responding to a specific incident, they're also able to help provide data on what went wrong from the perspective of urban design. They will be able to report back to the Department of Transportation, on what are some of the infrastructural issues that might be causing people to, are they not able to see the stop sign? Is there a tree branch blocking it? Right? So we hope that it can be somebody who is thinking whose main priority is traffic safety, not looking for crime. And Gosh really emphasized this a lot in our conversation that the traffic enforcement should always be done in conjunction with better design and engineering. So anytime you have a violation, you ask like, is there something about the way that these
街道的设计方式中，是否有某种东西本来是可以阻止这一发生的？是的，所以与目前警察完全脱离规划、工程和设计的方式不同——交通执法只是在所有这些东西之上又加了一层，而且他们根本不交流。是的，古什非常看好这一点，她认为许多交通问题实际上都是设计问题，我们可以非常显著地减少所需的执法量。
streets are designed that could have prevented this? Yeah, so instead of the way it is right now where police and it's totally distinct from planning and engineering and design, it's just a layer added on top of all that stuff. And they do not talk to each other at all. Yeah, and Goshis like very bullish on this that so many traffic problems are really design problems and that we can reduce the amount of enforcement that is needed really dramatically
街道的设计本可以阻止这种事的发生？是的，所以现在的状况是，警察部门与城市规划、工程设计完全割裂，这只是在所有这些工作之上额外加的一层。而且他们根本不交流。是的，Goshi非常支持这种观点，即许多交通问题实际上都是设计问题，我们可以大幅减少对执法的需求。
if these different agencies work together and share data and design streets that are safe streets. So in our interview I asked Sarah Sayo about this new policy in Berkeley and she said that she thinks it's really exciting and that it's a great way to reduce bad interactions between the public and the police because traffic stops are the number one way that people come into contact with law enforcement. And I think this makes a lot of sense for several reasons. One is that the police today are trained in what is called the Warrior mentality
如果这些不同的机构能够合作、共享数据并设计出安全的街道。所以在我们的采访中，我问了莎拉·萨约关于伯克利这项新政策的看法，她说她认为这真的令人兴奋，而且这是减少公众与警察之间不良互动的绝佳方式，因为交通拦截是人们与执法人员接触的首要途径。我认为这在几个原因下非常有意义。其一是现在的警察接受的是所谓的“战士心态”培训
because they are trained to deal with criminal suspects, to investigate crime, to pursue criminal investigations. They tend to see a lot of their encounters in that warrior mentality, which is not necessarily appropriate to traffic law enforcement when it's supposed to be a routine administrative task. I think that the history that I tell in my book
因为他们受训去处理刑事嫌疑人、调查犯罪、进行刑事调查。他们倾向于用那种战士心态来看待很多遭遇，这对于本应是例行行政任务的交通执法来说并不一定合适。我认为我在书中讲述的历史
points to some difficulties with this proposal or some challenges to this proposal that have to be addressed. And what are some of those logistical difficulties? The argument that I make in my book is that the police became professionalized, they became modernized, they gained a lot of discretionary power because of the challenges of enforcing traffic laws on the general public. I saw this history repeat itself in the 1990s New York City experiment with meter maids, where New York City has these traffic agents that are not police officers and they're informally called meter mates and they issue citations for low-level offenses mostly parking violations and they realize the same thing that traffic cops in the 1920s and 30s realized. Enforcing traffic laws on the general public is a really hard task and they got a lot of abuse. They were actually
指出了一些与这一提议相关的困难，或者说这一提议必须解决的一些挑战。那么其中一些后勤困难是什么呢？我在书中提出的论点是，警察之所以变得专业化、现代化，拥有大量自由裁量权，是因为在广大公众中执行交通法的挑战。我在20世纪90年代纽约市的“交通协管员”实验中看到了这段历史的重演，当时纽约市有这些不是警官的交通代理人，他们通常被非正式地称为“贴罚单的人”，他们对低级别的违法行为（主要是停车违章）开具罚单，他们意识到与20、30年代的交警意识到的一样的事情。在广大公众中执行交通法是一项非常艰难的任务，他们受到了很多辱骂。他们实际上
assaulting and so what they wanted, what they lobbied for was to have the status and the authority of police officers because they thought if I have the power of a police officer then the public won't abuse me or assault me when I'm directing traffic. And so basically in New York City, they did everything they could to make meter maids, more like police officers in the end. So they gave them blue uniforms, and they gave them more power, and in the case of they kind of reinvented the police.
遭到袭击，所以他们想要的、他们游说争取的是拥有警官的地位和权力，因为他们认为如果我拥有警官的权力，那么当我指挥交通时，公众就不会虐待我或攻击我。所以在纽约市，他们基本上竭尽全力让交通协管员最终变得更像警察。所以他们给他们穿上蓝色制服，赋予他们更多权力，在某种程度上他们重塑了警察。
Right, and then you wind up in a situation that looks an awful lot like the one you were trying to get away from. So Sarah says that if Berkeley is going to create this new class of traffic enforcer. The city is really going to have to work hard on public education and buy-in so that type of power and force is not required in this new enforcement body. So I think if the public understands the direct connection between their cooperation with traffic agents and societies reliance on policing, then that could go a long way towards not having to fall
没错，然后你最终会陷入一种看起来非常类似于你试图摆脱的局面的处境。因此，莎拉说，如果伯克利要建立这种新型的交通执法人员队伍，这座城市真的必须在公众教育和认同方面付出巨大努力，这样在这个新的执法机构中就不需要那种权力和武力了。所以我想，如果公众理解他们对交通代理人的配合与社会对警务的依赖之间的直接联系，那么这对于不必重新陷入
back into the cycle of increasing the discretionary authority of whoever it is that enforces traffic laws. So it's the really early stages of all this, but I think it's really exciting that people are trying to shake things up and try new things. Yeah, and interesting, I mean, it's cool for me to see Berkeley sort of at the center of all this history going back 100 years and now coming full circle. Yeah, it's like, it's almost poetic
提高任何交通执法人员自由裁量权的恶性循环将大有帮助。所以这一切还处于非常早期的阶段，但我认为人们试图打破常规并尝试新事物真的令人兴奋。是的，很有趣，我的意思是，看到伯克利成为所有这些历史的中心，回溯100年，现在又转了一圈回到原点，这对我来说很酷。是的，这几乎具有诗意
that it's happening here when it all kind of started here. So is so cool. Well, thanks so much for for for bringing us in having this interview. Thank you Yeah, of course. Thank you 99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald music by Sean Rial Delaney Hall is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, the rest of the team is Vivian Leigh, Chris Barube, Joe Rosenberg, Katie Mingle, Abby Maudon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KLW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, which lives at the far corners of North America, but is centered in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California.
它发生在这里，而这一切某种程度上也是从这里开始的。所以太酷了。非常感谢你带我们进来并进行这次采访。谢谢，是的，当然。谢谢。《99%无形》本周由埃mett Fitzgerald制作，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，团队的其他成员还有维维安·李、克里斯·巴鲁贝、乔·罗森伯格、凯蒂·明格、阿比·莫顿、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的一个项目，制作于Radio Row，它位于北美洲的遥远角落，但中心位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。
We are a founding member of Radio Topia, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listener supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can totally meet at Roman Mars in the show at 99pi, or we're on Instagram and read it too. We're gonna take a brief summer break so that we can breathe and prepare for all of our big plans in the fall about the book, which you can pre-order at 99pi.org slash book.
我们是Radio Topia的创始成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性、听众支持、100%艺术家拥有的独立播客组成的激烈独立的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 查找所有这些内容。你绝对可以在 99pi 上与罗曼·马尔斯会面，我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。我们将进行短暂的暑假，以便我们可以喘口气，并为我们在秋季关于这本书的所有宏伟计划做准备，你可以在 99pi.org/book 上预订这本书。
In the other special series, we have coming. There's so much good stuff coming on, but we just need a little bit of time to make it all happen and just also take a vacation. So listen to all those back episodes that you didn't get a chance to because of no commuting during COVID, but you can always keep taps on us online at n9nipe.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们即将推出的其他特别系列中。有那么多精彩的内容即将推出，但我们只需要一点时间来让这一切发生，同时也去度个假。所以，听听那些你在新冠疫情期间因为没有通勤而没有机会收听的往期节目，但你随时可以在在线网址 n9nipe.org 上关注我们的动态。来自 PRX 的 Radio Topia。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。